et je me suis arrêté particulièrement
sur le salaire de Benjamin Castaldi
que marche à ma castani s'en est plein
les fouilles mais non je ne connaissais
pas son salaire c'est vrai et j'ai
appelé mon directeur général tu dis tu
donnes autant que il m'a dit oui sinon
il serait pas venu j'ai mis viens pas
[Rires]
et donc vous avez une augmentation cette
année ah non
heureusement
Castaldi Castaldi à votre avis qui est
le plus payé de la table Castel
[Rires]
castaldies
[Musique]
ça fait des années qu'on la rémunération
il va falloir rémunérer sa participation
à l'émission
dit il arrête pas de se vanter de son
nouveau salaire l'autre jour il a pris
Ilias de ticket resto il faisait été mal
à qui je suis là comme ça
est-ce que vous trouvez que vous méritez
votre salaire absolument
et de plus en plus pourquoi parce que je
suis excellent vraiment non vous trouvez
bon dans l'émission bien sûr pas alors
pas tout le temps
passe le temps la proportion
une sur une sur 20 non non
une sur deux mais vous êtes fous et vous
Cyril vous êtes le chef vous décidez ça
vous souhaitez allez-y si vous avez
chacun votre tour votre la protection
des missions sur 5 mais vous trouvez bon
je comprends pas deux minutes et moi je
vous dirai après ce que j'en pense bon
nous chacun
[Rires]
sur cinq émissions que tu fais quand
même là de bonnes sur cinq
une au moins non
doigts
on est bon sur combien d'émissions sur 5
vu que moi je réagis avec mon coeur si
si les sujets ne m'intéressent pas je
réagis pas donc en fait c'est pas de ma
faute c'est en fonction de sujet donc
non non je suis bonne sur cinq donc
[Rires]
moi je dirais 3 ou je suis à peu près
correct d'accord toi 5 sur 5 ma gueule
maintenant
que je pense de vous vous avez dit vous
3 sur 5 pour moi c'est 2 sur 5 pour vous
avez dit combien 350
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
de trois sur cinq Guillaume c'est 3 sur
5 merci 3 sur 5 merci ma vie